and a lot of them are branching out in
Shan Rah's whereas a lot of them first
with it oh I only like to do
action-adventure I only like to do
romantic comedy and nowadays I hear them
branching out more I'm wanting to do
right I thought I'd you know I thought I
you know challenged myself so I thought
I'd do something a little different so
I'm doing a mystery alright yeah and
it's it's nice to hear that now that
they're doing that and I do think that I
think it makes it for a lot of the
agents it's not just looking at material
and saying what's where's that big tent
pole thing it's also what does this
particular rider have do they have that
that it's best word to use do they have
that sense of adventure of wanting to go
further with their talents as a writer
to go further and and look at other
pieces of material and write about
something that is totally different than
what's out there that's interesting how
do you think they can tell that someone
has that sense of adventure I think just
by talking to them and reading them what
are you working on you know what is it
because they want to know what it is
that you're working on oh yeah if I'm -
if they give a one-line answer like oh
I'm working on another action-adventure
or I'm well you know I like comedy so I
thought I'd do another comedy if you're
only working on what one genre or one
thing that they're that they that you
that maybe you you did well on your
first script and you're only working on
that yeah they're glad to hear that but
they want to know that there's more what
else are you giving them that's going to
be so different cuz think they have to
sell it they have to sell it the agents
have to sell it to the producers and the
producers have to sell it to the
distributors or the studios so an
openness and a willingness if they see
that you're too closed off then maybe
they realize it's a pass just because
down the wrong down the line it's just
not going to work okay yeah so other
fatal errors our writer make either even
in and just how they present themselves
or oh that's a good one
I feel that a lot of writers don't put
enough they don't invest enough in the
selves in terms of getting out there and
networking most common excuses are I
don't live in Hollywood or I don't know
somebody in the business or you know
they they you know they don't make that
investment nowadays social media you can
be just as up-to-date as anybody else
who lives in the city because you all
you have to do is just be able to go on
online develop a group like I said
there's writers groups that are online
and go to conferences invest in yourself
and that's I think that's one of the one
of the best pieces of advice I can give
to people consider investing in yourself
if this is something you want to do if
you're serious about it you go to a
college you go to college if you want to
be an engineer or a doctor then you have
to invest in yourself if you're going to
be a writer go to the writing
conferences or or they now have a lot of
them online do courses online invest in
in getting together with other
like-minded writers and going to write
or retreats or just going out and
looking at all the material that's out
there and taking courses to you know to
really further not just your writing but
to further your network I don't like
using the term network so much I like to
say building a community of contacts and
when you do that it really makes a
difference because that's where a lot of
the connections start getting made you
know like there are people who were I I
have clients where one of them you know
got an agent and there was another she
heard that her boss or her agent you
know that their agency was looking for
somebody who had an action-adventure
piece she remembered that the gal in her
class and her group had one and so she
got a synopsis and sent it to them now
they didn't buy it but they read the
synopsis and they said hey if you if you
you know if you have something else you
know feel free to send it to us they
didn't sign her but they expressed an
interest at looking at her work so just
that was just built built by the fact
that
she was in the same writers group as
this woman so that's that is one way you
can you you can do that I also suggest
that if if people are really serious
about their writing invest in going to a
consultant and really getting your
material read by a professional and
there's so many people that specialize
and that's what's great because if you
have something that you know what you
should just be consultant and maybe it
was just for film but look for somebody
who maybe has a specialty in television
or you know whatever your project is and
look for someone that has those
interests or who has developed material
along that line there are certain
parameters I think that that I know that
as a consultant I don't feel I can do
everything so sometimes there's what if
I if somebody contacts me and they say
oh I've got this horror picture and I'm
not uh you know I don't really I haven't
done as many in the horror genre
and if I don't feel I can give them
exactly what they want
I'm very good about recommending some of
my other consultants friends who you
know maybe would be better a better fit
but you know finding that right person
that you can consult with and help help
you really restructure your work well
that's important and not to you know I
remember that that not long ago a lot of
people said well yeah but you know I
have my writers group or or you know I
have a cousin that that was an English
major whatever it is and yes though
people like that are helpful but you
want to get it from people who have
either worked in the studios or have
been in worked in production or have
been with a producer worked in
television whatever the whatever area
that you're looking at you know what is
the what have they done and it's
important to do your due diligence it's
just part of investing in yourself and
taking the time to research that and I
think a lot of writers don't because
they're so eager they just say oh okay
and they just Google consultants and
35,000 names really come out you know
it's your due diligence to go through
and check them all out and to go you
know and
check out with other writers and find
out go online and say hey you know I've
got a script it's a sci-fi anybody else
have a sci-fi and who did you get as a
consultant and once you get a few names
run them through the ringer and in
Google and see who you get and who comes
out on top it's word of mouth is so
important I do think that you sometimes
people are really good at pitching and
then they don't have the material to
back them up and then we have conversely
right we have writers who have great
material but they have not spent enough
time learning how to pitch that's a huge
mistake I you know you can do pitching
things online you can do you can also go
go - like script fest there's a lot of
other you know organizations that have I
think there's virtual pitch fest - but
there's and I'll give you listings for
that one also but you can go to these
these different areas and say hey you
know I want to learn more and sit in on
the on the panels and the discussions
and do some of the practice pitches and
that's a lot of fun to do actually it's
somewhat and I do a course in fact I'm
doing one for the big break people where
I'm gonna have them pitch their projects
to me and I'm gonna pretend that you
don't be the studio exact and it's it's
gonna be a lot of fun I I look at it as
a good rehearsal for them because during
the the event itself the awards event
they're gonna be sitting next to agents
and producers and some of the people
that could make or break their career
you